voy a introducirlos ahora a la noción de
la eficiencia de una máquina y cuando
pensamos en una máquina por supuesto
pensamos en un refrigerador o en un
motor ok estoy representado por la letra
griega eta que suena lo mejor como pero
en realidad se parece como una en el
chistoso na ok entonces esta es la
eficiencia y la eficiencia se aplica a
las máquinas de la misma forma que lo
entendemos en todos los días por ejemplo
qué tan eficiente eres con tu tiempo me
interesa saber que estás haciendo con
una hora que se te dio por ejemplo qué
tan eficiente eres con el dinero y es
que tanto puedes comprar con 100 dólares
por ejemplo así que la eficiencia es que
tanto puedes hacer con algo que te
dieron así que en el mundo de las
máquinas definimos la eficiencia que sea
como el trabajo realizado entre él
esencialmente vamos a regresar por
ejemplo al mundo de las máquinas de
carne no aquí teníamos que es lo que lo
único que tenía aquí la energía el único
lugar de donde viene la energía desde
las de los depósitos de calor verdad
cuando nos movíamos de ave cuando nos
movíamos de ave ahí estamos inyectando
un calor q1 así que esencialmente este
sistema se mantiene en equilibrio
hacemos un proceso cuasi estático y
demás y todo eso pero tenemos que tener
en cuenta que teníamos un depósito de
calor que inyectaba calor q1 al sistema
y que es equivalente al trabajo que
hicimos a lo largo de ese periodo de
tiempo así que todo es bueno el trabajo
por cierto de una máquina recordemos que
es el área contenida en este ciclo ahora
lo que nos interesa es el calor que
nosotros le dimos a la máquina en este
caso sólo es que uno
y cuál fue el trabajo que hicimos bueno
el trabajo neto que hicimos será el área
sombreada verdad en el área dentro de
este ciclo de carnota así que nuestra
tesis definición para la eficiencia
podría estar dado en términos de un
porcentaje por ejemplo 0.56 estamos
diciendo que es 56 por ciento de
efectivo ok o eficiente es decir que de
todo lo que le dimos sólo el 56 por
ciento se se tradujo en el trabajo útil
ok
esa sería nuestra definición de
eficiencia ahora vamos a ver si podemos
jugar un poquito con esto y ver cómo la
eficiencia podría jugar cierto papel
importante al trabajar con los ciclos de
carnota así que cuál es el trabajo que
realizamos bueno sabemos de nuestra
definición de energía interna que el
cambio en la energía interna ok de hecho
ha sido más útil de lo que esperábamos
esta fórmula verdad nuestro cambio la
energía interna es el valor neto
aplicado ok y el calor neto aplicado
déjenme ponerle una n de neto
ok el calor aplicado al sistema menos el
trabajo hecho por el sistema verdad
ahora cuando completamos un ciclo de
carne cuando vamos de todo todo este
transcurso y de hecho voy voy a hacer un
poquito del lado de esto porque
podríamos pensar en un ciclo pero al
revés verdad en en sentido antihorario y
en ese caso estaríamos pensando en un
refrigerador en un refrigerador de
carnets ok entonces esencialmente sería
un refrigerador porque tendríamos
trabajo realizado para ti ok en ese
sentido estaríamos transfiriendo energía
en el sentido opuesto ok pero bueno
vamos a después dar una prueba de que en
la máquina de carnet es la máquina más
eficiente en este sentido ok entonces
pensemos si vamos en un ciclo alrededor
de esta gráfica en el diagrama presión
volumen si en donde empecé pues nuestro
cambio de temperatura es cero perdón el
cambio de la energía interna es cero
porque es una variable de estado
y cuando vamos de a y de vuelta a sólo
depende de su posición así que el cambio
en la energía interna es cero y cuál es
el calor neto aplicado al sistema bueno
pensemos en el calor neto aplicado al
sistema bueno primero aplicamos q1 al
sistema okay cuando íbamos de ave y
luego le quitamos q2 cuando íbamos de
shehadeh ok eso se debe a nuestro
segundo depósito de calor que tenía
temperatura t 2 y luego le tendremos
menos el trabajo ok y todo eso es 0 ok
todo esto el kun o menos q 2 es el calor
neto aplicado ok así que el trabajo
hecho por el sistema lo podemos ver de
la siguiente forma el trabajo es igual a
1 menos q2 y ahí lo tenemos simplemente
esto lo sustituimos acá arriba y en vez
de w ponemos q 1 - q 2
todo esto bueno nuestra definición de
eficiencia ahí lo tenemos y luego todo
eso lo dividimos entre 1 y podemos hacer
un poquito de
es verdad porque el primer sumando
podemos dividir con 1 por cada uno de
los de estos términos entonces con 1
entre 1 simplemente nos da 1 - q 2 sobre
q 1
muy bien así que otra vez esta es una
definición interesante de lo que es la
eficiencia y todas son manipulaciones
algebraicas usadas de esta definición
que viene también de la energía interna
ahora veamos cómo podemos relacionar
esto a nuestras temperaturas ok este es
con uno por cierto ok que que son q25
uno bueno esos vamos a pensar los en en
términos de valores absolutos es decir
vamos a pensar que cultos si fue
transferido fuera del sistema pero q2 en
términos de la energía podría ser un
número negativo y y realmente quiero
dejarlos todos en en términos positivos
así que la magnitud de q no
ok déjenme déjenme pintar otro ciclo
solo solo para que sea más más claro y
limpio
ok ahí están mis ejes de volumen y de
presión que es el de presión y el de
volumen y empezamos digamos en algún
punto a no sé y nos vamos a lo largo de
una curva isoterma cuál es qué color
sería por ejemplo morado ok nos vamos a
lo largo de una curva isoterma por aquí
nos vamos para hacia abajo hasta este
otro estado aunque éste es el estado ahí
este es el estado ve y sabemos que esta
es una curva isoterma entonces cuando
uno fue agregado
eso es una isoterma si tu temperatura no
cambio tu energía interna tampoco cambio
y como dije anteriormente si tu energía
interna de cero entonces el calor
aplicado al sistema es el mismo que el
trabajo que realizamos se cancela en
verdad así que si aquí metimos uno que
es el trabajo que realizamos y el
trabajo que hicimos es simplemente el
área debajo de esta curva seguiremos
dicho esto ya múltiples veces y eso es
porque hacemos un montón de rectángulos
de presión por volumen verdad presión
por volumen son rectángulos y entonces
al sumar todos ellos de forma infinita
entonces obtenemos el área y bueno qué
es eso sólo como un repaso de la presión
estamos estamos expandiendo el cilindro
en donde estamos moviendo un pistón ya
hemos hecho esto muchísimas gracias así
que uno simplemente es la integral de dv
efe
ok no no no debería ponerme final b b de
nuestro volumen no perdón tampoco
empezamos en na ahora sí vamos desde el
volumen hasta el volumen b así desde
donde empezamos hasta donde terminamos y
tomamos la integral de la presión de la
presión y la presión esto
la presión es simplemente la altura
verdad debe ok es la integral de la
presión debe y volvemos a nuestra
fórmula del gas ideal donde pb es igual
la nrc dividimos ambos lados por baked
atp es en rt sobre b
y entonces tenemos que que uno es igual
a la integral desde a hasta bbb de esta
expresión que es n r t sobre b dv y todo
esto de acá arriba son constantes porque
nos estamos moviendo en una interna
entonces este en realidad debería
decirte uno que es la temperatura ok en
realidad estamos tocando el depósito a
temperatura de uno entonces todo esto
sale de la integral y cuando ya hemos
evaluado esto muchísimas muchísimas
veces no me voy a centrar mucho en la
mecánica de la integral pero bueno esto
será nrc por bueno te uno por supuesto y
esta integral definida es la integral de
1 sobre b que es el logaritmo natural de
b pero como se restan los logaritmos
naturales simplemente es el logaritmo
natural del cociente de bb entre b
ok b b / b y eso es porque la resta de
logaritmos es el logaritmo del cociente
y ahí tienes que uno quien escudos pudo
ser a esta parte del ciclo de carnota
cuando nos vamos de c a d
muy bien nos vamos deseada y es el q2
así que la magnitud de co2 del aire es
el área debajo de esta curva
ok es el área debajo de esta curva pero
esté en un signo negativo porque es el
trabajo hecho para el sistema no por el
sistema ok entonces bueno consideremos
eso pero si queremos saber la magnitud
de q2 simplemente tomamos el área debajo
de esta curva aunque el área debajo de
esta curva
ok cuál es eso ese es el calor que se
salió del sistema debido a que tenemos
un depósito más frío así que la integral
podríamos decir que es igual o qué q2
déjenme ponerlo déjenme ponerlo de este
lado entonces q 2 es igual y vamos a
hacerlo exactamente igual verdad es la
misma lógica nada más cambiando las
fronteras verdad entonces vamos de veces
a veces pero como queremos saber el
valor absoluto de q2 en realidad vamos a
ir debe de abc que es el signo contrario
de veces
abed espero que haya sido un poquito
claro eso el punto es que vamos a ir dvd
dvd a veces todo para que esto sea un
término positivo recordemos el ciclo que
fuimos de bs a bb pero queremos el valor
absoluto así que queremos que esto sea
positivo así que lo invertimos el orden
entonces tenemos de la presión respecto
al volumen y hacemos exactamente lo
mismo tenemos que dos sería igual a nr
de dos en este caso este dos verdad por
el logaritmo natural logaritmo natural
de quien de veces sobre bebé aunque es
el logaritmo natural de en vez de bebé
entre vea va a ser veces sobre bebé ok
entonces esto será veces sobre b de
perfecto
muy bien ahora usemos estos dos estas
dos ecuaciones esta información para
volver al resultado de la eficiencia que
teníamos
sabemos que la eficiencia era igual a 1
- cu cu cú déjeme ver como lo teníamos q
2 entre 1 entonces uno menos q 2 / q1
ahora si sustituimos esto que vamos a
tener vamos a sustituir estos acá
entonces tenemos esta la eficiencia es
uno menos q 2 que es esto
n rt 2 por el logaritmo natural de veces
sobre b d
y ahora todo esto lo dividimos por q1
pero quienes con un cubo no simplemente
es esta expresión de aquí arriba que es
n rt 1 ok por por el logaritmo natural
de bb sobre b
ahora podemos saber hacer algunas
cancelaciones por aquí por ejemplo en
reserva y además tenemos estos
logaritmos naturales pero tuvimos todo
un vídeo completo dedicado a demostrar
que veces sobre el bebé era igual a bebé
sobre b
así que esto que está dentro si estos
son iguales esto que está dentro son
iguales y por lo tanto los logaritmos
naturales son iguales y con que nos
quedamos simplemente con el hecho de que
la eficiencia también puede expresarse
como 1 - de 2 sobre de 1 en un ciclo en
una máquina de carnota ok entonces la
eficiencia está escrito en términos de
la temperatura en un ciclo de kart no de
esta forma
ok simplemente hicimos un poquito de
matemáticas con estas definiciones
respecto al trabajo y bueno todo lo que
ya hemos hecho múltiples veces verdad
pero todo esto es para una máquina de
carne porque hicimos un poquito de
trabajo esté suponiendo todo lo que
hemos ya dicho para los ciclos de
carnota ok en el próximo vídeo de hecho
vamos a demostrar qué
eficiencia de una máquina moviéndonos a
lo largo de una isoterma entre dos
temperaturas no puedes obtener una
máquina más eficiente que la que la de
una máquina de carnota ok así que
no sabemos en qué sentido puede hacer
una práctica una máquina práctica pero
al menos estoy diciendo que la más
eficiente entre estas dos temperaturas o
estos dos depósitos de temperatura